[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
but there's one thing that's cool about
the medium it feels empowering I think
that's why it's so effective as a form
of escapism and why overpowered
characters are so popular amongst the
teenage populace so for today our list
is about some of my favorite Showcases
of power done by younger teenage
characters on people who on the eye test
would have blown them out of the water
Asian experience that's nothing
if you thought Japanese light novel
characters are overpowered let me
introduce you to what Chinese novels
have been given us there are lots of
series long-running series that will put
people like rimuru or tatsuya to shame
and one of those is daily life of
immortal King the name should have given
you enough hints already but actions
speak louder than words so I present to
you this video of Wang Ling easily
annihilating The Demon King and saving
the world with how he nonchalantly no
cells the attacks and sends the enemy
packing it's giving me flashbacks of
arnos yeah I think with how powerful
Wang Ling has been established in the
series no one less than arnos himself
can match how hilariously overpowered
this guy is oh saitama I suppose
whichever genre you prefer the point is
if you need any more proof of how
overpowered Chinese novel characters can
be take note the daily life of immortal
King is just the tip of the iceberg
after that we move on to kilowatt versus
Jonas
if there's an opponent needed to match
kilua's training as a member of the
zoldiac family it's got to be someone
like Jonas right A notorious mass
murderer with a sadistic streak Jonas
has no shortage of sadism and confidence
in himself this is a guy who takes
pleasure from murders and gleefully
Embraces the feeling of Flesh and Blood
a perfect match will take kilowatt to
the Limit right wrong for all the
supposed hype and big talks surrounding
Jonas he just gets easily destroyed by
kilua in a blink of an eye Mr mass
murderer here gets his heart plucked out
and crushed quickly putting an end to
the death match he didn't even have a
chance to comprehend what hit him if
that's not a way to show off kilua's
prowess in the most dominating manner
possible then I don't know what is
foreign
before we continue how about a treat
watching the best anime videos
necessitates the best food around and my
personal recommendation for you is
today's sponsor Tokyo treat and sakurako
their subscription-based snack boxes
that aim to give you the best and most
authentic Japan experience on one hand
we have the Tokyo treat box which
includes up to 20 exclusive limited
edition and seasonal Japanese snacks
like Japanese special KitKat soda Ramen
and many more and this month's theme is
Akiba Adventure yet Tokyo tree looks to
take you on a trip through Japan's pop
culture Heaven speaking of we've got a
special KitKat flavor for this month
only Autumn Chestnut as for the sakurako
box it includes 20 authentic and Artisan
Japanese snacks tea and kitchenware and
we have a theme that's just as cool bet
you didn't know about colyo right Goyo
is the tradition related to appreciating
the seasonal change brought by four it's
where people go out and admire the
beautiful four foliage and sakurako has
some autumnal sweets to help you get in
the mood I personally really like the
one that Mochi if any of the boxes
interest you head over to the
description box and start ordering and
don't forget to use the code Vinnie to
get five dollars off your first box
there's a lot to like in Jiu Jitsu
kaizen's prequel movie Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
zero a few lists ago I covered a nice
Gojo fight from the movie but it's time
we focus the spotlight on another
character this time Utah it's nice
seeing Utah get his time to shine in the
movie he and Geto had a fight that's
worth a thousand words so here's the
clip to let you experience the action
for yourself you've got to love those
camera angles and how they make fights
really intense more importantly for this
list though is the fact that we've got
another candidate for the most powerful
anime punches here talk about a huge
momentum shift after how get those seem
to have the upper hand for most of the
fight a comeback made even more amazing
with how it's presented and the magic of
cinematic quality I expected Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen on the big screen to look great
but this is just taking it to another
level
for someone not on the protagonist side
for once here's Obito's rage moment
[Applause]
there are a few things that are stronger
motivators for anime characters than
seeing the death of a loved one we often
associate that with the heroes but even
villains have those moments too and
those often lead them down their
diverging paths take Obito for example
seeing Rin die at the hands of gakashi
was enough for him to awaken the
mangekyo Sharingan and that's to say
that the results ain't pretty especially
if you're one of the poor souls in the
vicinity it's a Slaughter like no other
and it didn't matter if Obito is
completely outnumbered there are a few
things that compare to the power of an
angry Obito wielding one of the most
powerful weapons in the Naruto Universe
even at his young age he'd already shown
tremendous power no wonder he became
such a thorn for the heroes as he grew
yeah
[Applause]
agura versus abuto is up next
beware the nice ones are super common
say and frankly it's become cliche at
some points already yeah anime
protagonists seem to forget this all the
time like when Abu Dro pushes one button
too many when he fights shinbachi and
kagura after handling his business quite
well abudo decided to go for more to
relish the moment and let gargura see
shinpachi in quite the most tragic way
possible big mistake though as all this
does is awaken gargura's yato blood and
the rest is history this is a gargura
that we just don't see gone was the old
kagura and what we have in place here is
a deranged killing machine even drawing
comparisons to kamui even as avaldo
tries fighting back it's all futile
against the Unleashed gargura and he
very nearly loses his life in the
process it's a one-sided route there's
no other way to put it our strongest
instincts get awakened in the midst of a
pinch and when some of the nicest people
get pushed to a corner the results ain't
pretty arbuto had to learn this the hard
way
who's boss in the next scene
there are many things to remember mob
psycho season one for but if we're
talking simple flexing of Power by our
unassuming teenage hero this one's
probably it this is the highlight of the
season going on my does seem to get the
upper hand at first roughing up our hero
a little bit but when the gloves come
off then it's over much like the kagura
moment this is one of those super rage
moments triggered by seeing a friend in
danger but in comparison to that I think
this one is a tad better in terms of
animation and presentation then again it
is Mob psycho we're talking about so
that is a no-brainer on another note
I've always appreciated how the psychic
meter gets utilized in early mob psycho
it gives a sense of escalation and with
it a lot of anticipation for viewers to
see the moment when mob does reach its
Breaking Point
next up is Luffy's Red Rock moment
against kaido
is this the climax of one piece or what
for a lot of people it does feel like
him after so much build up the fight
with kaido is here and to say that it
broke all expectations is an
understatement the long Clash that pits
Our Heroes and their allies against the
Beast Pirates has been a ride and I
don't think that Clips alone could do it
any justice it's the payoff to a long
build up in an arc that has quickly
become my favorite and of course we have
some Landmark moments that include Luffy
finally managing to land a decisive hit
on the previously impervious kaido as
someone who's been built as a crazy op
villain seeing Luffy bring kaido to his
knees was such a great treat but to do
it like that and with the op playing
Goosebumps I tell you Goosebumps as I
said Clips don't do it justice even if
you're a lapsed one-piece fan who only
follows spoilers at least watch this
Clash it might reignite your love for
the franchise with how awesome it is in
anime form
[Music]
lastly we have Ichigo versus Eisen
how appropriate just as bleach made its
much awaited return as an anime we get
to relive this fight and remember how
Ichigo just flexed his power over Eisen
for so long Eisen has been this
Untouchable unbeatable villain who's
always about five steps ahead of
everyone else post dangai Ichigo however
is a completely different beast and for
the first time we truly see izen become
unhinged at the prospect of possibly
fighting or being stronger than he is
it's got all the Hallmarks of a bleach
style ass kicking to drive home the
point that yes Ichigo here is far and
above the strongest being in universe as
of the time of this episode entire
mountains being leveled by slashes
high-powered kiddos being though sold
and Ichigo even getting a measure of
Revenge by stopping izen's sword with
his bare hands it's a true Showcase of
power and the way the scene plays out it
really drove the point home
[Music]
that just about wraps up my list
finishing with bleach just seems right
but is that your favorite Showcase of
Power by a teenage character tell me
what you think about the list in the
comments section also you might want to
check out the rest of the channel for
more videos that you might like I hope
you like watching the video thanks again
and I'll see you next time